no no, please no please please don't
hurt him it's just a child
please no
the dark side of the force is a pathway to
many abilities some consider to be unnatural
what did you do to it,
what did you do to it. I protected him I
protected him if it wasn't for me he
would already be dead please
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Mandalorian video for
the secret plan that the empire has four
baby Yoda why do they want him so bad if
you're new to the channel I do videos
for all the episodes and Easter eggs
there's also big movie stuff obviously
coming up because it's December as I'm
posting this video we're doing a merch
giveaway too all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your best
theory about what the Emperor wants with
baby Yoda on the video cursory spoiler
warning for everything that's happened
on the Mandalorians so far most of what
we're talking about deals with stuff
from episodes 2 & 3 but there are a
couple other clues from the other
episodes as well the most important baby
Yoda seen so far in terms of evil empire
plots in explaining what's going on are
from episodes 2 and episodes 3 during
episode 2 we get confirmation of a
detail that we already kind of knew
members of Yoda's race are all born
extremely force-sensitive and even
though he's still a baby by the
standards of his race or a youngling
whatever you want to call him he's
already super powerful holding the giant
mud horn that probably weighs a hundred
times what he does in the air for an
extended period of time before he
collapses from the strain a lot of
people at the end of episode 4 also
thought that he would be able to use the
force to instinctively deflect the
Bounty Hunter's rifle shot but I don't
think that's the case I think he's only
able to perform those great feats like
the mud horn when he concentrates very
hard and even that put him down for
about half a day yes he does seem like
he has ninja-like powers of
teleportation and instant transmission
if we're talking about Dragon Ball
skills appearing out of thin air to
break the tension by slurping his soup
those are all really funny but that's
more of an editing cheat that the show
uses in the name of comedy during
episode 1 in episode 3 you hear dr.
Pershing talk about the kid in a really
important way it was very important to
him that he get him back alive and was
extremely excited when his scans showed
that he was super healthy as if that
would somehow be even better for the
Empire's plans Verner Herzog's character
who seems like an important person
within the remnants of the Empire seemed
like he could care less whether or not
baby Yoda was brought back alive and
didn't seem like he was on very good
turn
with dr. Pershing like he didn't enjoy
working with him the way the doctor was
reacting to everything especially during
episode when we first meet him just
makes it seem like he's really jumpy
around the stormtroopers like he doesn't
like being here working with these
people even though he himself is also
part of the Empire that couple with the
idea that he wanted to protect baby Yoda
just makes it seem like he has a more
complicated relationship with the Empire
yes he works for an evil organization
but he's not completely evil himself I
think that'll be more important for
later in the series but we've all talked
about the Kamino and cloning symbols on
Doctor Pershing's Imperial uniform
confirming that he works at the cloning
facility for the Empire or he worked
there for the Empire when the Emperor
was still alive
technically the Empire doesn't exist
anymore so all the Admirals in
higher-level officials like the moths
that were left in the wake of the
remnants of the Empire have seized what
power they could so technically the
Empire is still around but it's not the
empire that we knew before is a bunch of
different people calling the shots if
you haven't read a lot of the extended
and new Star Wars Canon there are a
bunch of new comics that tell you more
of what happened in and around the Clone
Wars supposedly according to the new
Darth Vader comics it's detailed that
after the Clone Wars in the last batch
of Republic clones had been delivered
the plan was for the Emperor to formally
shut down the cloning facility
completely no more clones for anyone but
cue Darth Plagueis the wise speech the
tragedy of Darth Plagueis the wise the
Emperor was obsessed with a couple of
things one knowledge of the force to
immortality and three ruling the galaxy
you need a couple things to accomplish
all those goals you need a giant army
and you would need more clones there's
even an easter egg in the newer Star
Wars films where they talk about the
idea that they want to go back to using
clones for their armies because they
felt that they were more reliable than
the methods that are using in
present-day
the present day of the new films so the
whole idea is that all these Imperials
left around want more clones and the
Emperor was supposed to quote/unquote
have closed the cloning facility but I
think we can assume that he probably
didn't and he just kept it open as a
side project in secret some more
evidence that the cloning facility has
still been operating this whole time
during the course of the original
trilogy is that you look at the
stormtroopers here
five years after Return of the Jedi look
at their stormtrooper uniforms and how
decrepid and dirty they are either
they're just really crappy stormtroopers
and they don't care about keeping their
uniforms clean or this is just meant to
be a sign of the state of the Empire
everything is slowly crumbling to dust
the Empire itself is crumbling but dr.
Pershing is wearing this shiny brand-new
looking Imperial cloning uniform as if
he in the cloning facility beyond the
outer rim have been operating this whole
time insulated from the war with the
rebellion I think that's just
confirmation that the Emperor was
running a lot of secret cloning tests
and experiments on the side while this
is all going on so it's probably safe to
assume that this is all part of
Palpatine's grand plan but when he died
and you have all these warlords seizing
power a lot of Palpatine secret projects
were being co-opted by the Admirals and
the other moths that are left in the
wake of the Empire so here's a real
important distinction there I think some
things that are going on during rise of
Skywalker that seems similar to what
they're implying is going on in the
Mandalorian with baby Yoda in this
cloning facility but because of what JJ
Abrams and Jon Favreau and Dave Filoni
have said I think that the Mandalorian
TV show isn't directly going to connect
with what's happening in rise of
Skywalker it just seems like there are
some similarities and yes I do think
that baby Oda will survive into the
future and become the future of the Jedi
Order but before we talk about secret
baby Yoda plans I just don't think the
baby Yoda is going to show up during rise
of Skywalker and save the day it's not
going to be some deus ex machina or
anything like that because Yoda's race
is so powerful the emperor would have
loved to have been able to study his
biology in greater detail but couldn't
because Yoda would have discovered his
secret too early and revealed him and
then once he was revealed as Darth
Sidious Yoda had sequestered himself
secretly to Dagobah where the emperor
couldn't find him on the other side of
the galaxy
yeah doll had also disappeared after
Phantom Menace and believed to be dead
so the emperor couldn't find her either
and they were the only two known members
of their race at that time now we know
that's not true because baby Yoda is
about 50 years old which means he was
born at about the same time that Anakin
Skywalker was meaning that he predates
the prequels and predates the creation
of the Clone Army in attack of the
clones which is why I don't think that
the kid is a clone of Yoda but I
do think that dr. Pershing's
conversation with werner herzog in
Episode three where he tells the doctor
to hurry up and get his samples than
dispose of the kid implies that he's
taking complete genetic scans of DNA
from the kid in order to create a new
clone army not necessarily a clone army
of tiny little Yoda's even though that
would be adorable the Kamino ends were
able to tamper with the genetic makeup
of the original clothes to give them
traits or take traits away from them I
think the plans for what they were doing
at the cloning facility changed after
the galaxy believed the Emperor died
during Return of the Jedi and the
Imperials left who seized what power
they could now want to use the cloning
facility in baby Yoda's DNA to create a
new army of super force sensitive clones
that they can control and clones that
have super long lifespans way longer
than normal humans I saw some people
reacting to this scene in particular
with him on the bio bed and thought that
dr. Pershing was literally extracting
midi-chlorians from baby Yoda that's not
what he's doing you can't take someone's
midi-chlorians like you can take their
blood samples but you can clone Jedi's
they did it during legends during the
Thrawn Trilogy when the clone of another
jedi master cloned a new version of luke
skywalker using the severed hand that he
lost a cloud city that the emperor
collected and then later stored for use
the clone of luke skywalker even though
it was a little weird wound up being
just as force-sensitive as the original
version of luke and even though legends
isn't supposed to be canon anymore Dave
Filoni has recanted eyes a ton of legend
stuff fraud being the best example so
it's just an example that it is possible
to create a bunch of force-sensitive
clones if you have the right DNA samples
and baby yoda is one of the most
force-sensitive beings in the galaxy
because of his race but like I said I
don't think that what they're doing with
baby Yoda in the Mandalorian series is
directly connected to what's going on
with rise of Skywalker
I think the rise of Skywalker stuff is
completely separate for everyone asking
what's going on with baby Yoda in the
present day of the Star Wars timeline
you also have to remember that they aged
so slowly that even in present day 25
plus years when the new trilogy is
happening he'd still be very very young
he'd have to be closer to 80 or a
hundred years old before he'd be old
enough to begin any kind of formal Jedi
training or any
like that and you have to remember to
there is no Jedi Order right now there
are just a couple of really
force-sensitive people that will
probably slowly start coming together
and rebuild the Jedi Order but I do
think that he is critical to the future
of the Jedi just someone who can live
and connect all the different future
generations because he'll live so long
you also have to wonder if Giancarlo
Esposito smoth Gideon character is the
one that's behind this big cloning plot
because he used to be an imperial moth
before the fall of the Empire now as
Gina Carano scare achter implies he's
more of a warlord who's just taking
command of all the Imperial assets that
he could in the sector so maybe he is
the evil person behind this plot because
Werner Herzog's character even though he
seems like he's a very important person
doesn't seem like the most important
person we still haven't gotten his name
but he is still alive he wasn't killed
at the end of episode 3 so it's implied
that he will come back at some point
early prediction they do get their hands
on baby Yoda at some point in dr.
Pershing is critical to them rescuing
baby Yoda and he winds up flipping sides
before the end of the series but
everyone posts all your theories in the
comments below what is their grand plan
for the cloning facility and baby Yoda
there'll be more Mandalorian bonus
videos this week post all your requests
in the comments below
congratulations gage Williams you're the
giveaway winner from my last big video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your contact
details every one click here for my
Mandalorian episode 4 video and click
here for my full history on the
Mandalorian race thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!